the season 5 finale of arrow brought
back a bunch of fan favorite characters
for an epic showdown on Lian Yu and
culminated in an explosive cliffhanger
you became weary lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I want to take a look
at that season 5 cliffhanger ending and
see if we can figure out who survived
and who's returning for season 6 a quick
reminder that my arrow verse giveaway is
still running so for a chance to win any
of these arrow flash or Supergirl Funko
pops subscribe and leave a comment with
your thoughts on the finale or season 6
and just be aware that obviously there
are spoilers ahead if you're not up to
date yet with arrow so this season
prometheus was certainly the villain
we've been looking for on arrow always
ten steps ahead of Oliver I really enjoy
Josh Sagaris performance and his
character was so irredeemably bad that
he even killed himself at the end hoping
to destroy Oliver's life by setting off
the bombs on Lian Yu to kill almost
everyone that Ollie cared about as
shocking as this was this is of course a
comic book show and unless we see bodies
dead and buried and even sometimes then
it's hard to believe that they are all
really dead on top of that various
characters that are on the island at the
end have already been confirmed for
season 6 by the showrunners so let's
examine who probably made it and how
they survived actress Katie Cassidy had
already been confirmed to return as
black siren for season 6 and given she
was working with Prometheus it's quite
likely she was aware of the bombs he'd
set on the island so she probably had a
means of getting off the island already
arranged as black siren is coming back
as a regular next season I wonder
whether she could even get a main
villain role it's not for the whole
season
then perhaps at least initially an
actors Julianne Harvey and Ric cansado
if you play Dinah and Renee are also
confirmed as returning to season 6 in
the finale we finally see Dinah
validated as a new Black Canary by
Quentin Lance which is nice because
Dinah was the original Black Canary in
the comics before Laurel Lance took on
the mantle but how did she wild dog and
the others survive all those bombs
remember Oliver says to Felicity there's
an Argus supply ship on the eastern side
of the island but that appears to be
just minutes before the bombs go off so
it seems unlikely they could have made
it there in time however let's not
forget that Slade will
person is with them and he knows me I
knew well and it's just spent many years
locked up in a reinforced Super Max
prison on the island so I suspect that
Slade probably took as many of them as
he could the safety of the Argus prison
bunker speaking of Deathstroke
given it in the finale Oliver gives
Slade Wilson a file with information on
his son Joe it seems unlikely that the
show would open up this thread without
exploring it further down the road which
suggests that there are possible
storylines ahead about Slade looking for
his son now Manu Bennett is currently
busy with other roles so whether he will
return or how much he could return for
season six is still unsure Deathstroke
was a great character when he was a
regular on the show and with the finale
cameo of Oliver's mother Moira who Slade
killed in season two it would be amazing
to see Deathstroke return and further
redeem himself next season
felicity Diggle seer Curtis Quentin and
Nyssa were also with Slade Dinah Rene at
the end and obviously it wouldn't be a
good move for the show to kill off these
main characters in between seasons I
suspect most of them made it to safety
with Slade but there's always a chance
we get to see a few of them picked off
in the opening episode of season six
for example SIA has had a lot less to do
this season so you could argue that
she'd be the most obvious one to go
however I feel she won't be killed off
on the island especially as Merlyn may
have given his life to save hers but
could to show pull a similar move to
what the flash did this season with HR
and Tracy in other words did they
rekindle the romance between Felicity
and Oliver's a way to raise the stakes
for her character before possibly
killing her off after all Prometheus did
say that Oliver is going to be lonely
without mum and Felicity just before he
blew up the island or given the fact
there's little audience attachment to
the character maybe it'll be Samantha
the mother of Oliver's son William who
doesn't make it awfully I knew a couple
of baddies whose faith is less certain
would be Evelyn and Talia Evelyn was
last seen still locked up in the cage
and Talia had been knocked out by Nyssa
so you can never totally count out a
character who've got the name al Ghul
now let's not forget about another tease
but not seem death during the finale
Malcolm merlyn's Merlyn took Thea's
place after she stepped on a landmine
and sent her away with the others after
digger Harkness aka Captain Boomerang
and his gang caught up with them
see you then Thorne explode
in the distance--and assumed merlin had
died but remember Slade Wilson's words
to boomerang earlier in the episode
assumption is the mother of all failures
however John Barrowman who plays merlin
made a facebook video shortly after the
episode finished saying that he won't be
back to season 6 and that he's very sad
to be leaving the arrow verse so it
looks like this is the end for merlin
then but at least he was able to redeem
himself somewhat by sacrificing himself
for his daughter of course we're still
in comic book territory here so it is
possible that the showrunners decided to
leave Merlin's potential death off
screen to leave things more open for the
future after all Merlyn was looking
pretty cocky when boomerang turned up
and it's not unfeasible that he could
have pulled boomerang onto the landmine
while launching himself as far away as
he could from the explosion and let's
not forget this green vial he wears
around his neck if that contains water
from the Lazarus Pit then he could use
it to heal any major injuries from the
blast Malcolm has returned from apparent
death before and has dubbed himself the
magician both in the TV show and the
comics so even if he did die we can't
absolutely rule out his return even if
it's only in flashbacks so who do you
think survived Lian Yu and what did you
think about the arrow season finale also
what would you like to see happen in
season 6 don't forget to comment and
subscribe to enter my arrow burst Funko
pop giveaway and if you enjoyed this do
please leave a like and while you're
here check out my slash Supergirl and
other DC TV and movie videos by tapping
or clicking the links here thanks for
watching and see you next time epic a
movie lovers